You ready for this, Aniston?
I’m ready, bubbe.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
What is Adam Sandler's
favorite color, do you know?
Fluorescent orange.
I do like that.
You love that color.
You know why?
Why?
Orange crush soda.
Always loved that.
I didn't know that part.
Now I know that part.
When did you and I first meet?
I know when that happened.
Do you?
Of course I do.
We were young at Jerry's Deli,
and we had breakfast together.
You had eggs with ham and cheese.
And what did I have?
French toast?
And I washed it down with?
Oh oh, chocolate milk.
Like a grown man should.
Boom.
What's my go-to condiment?
I know what you love.
What?
Raw onions.
Old mustard.
Relish and some chopped up fingernails.
First of all, I've never
ordered a hot dog in your presence.
I love. Well, my favorite mayonnaise.
You love mayonnaise?
That's good stuff.
Well, when's Jen's birthday?
You would know that one.
I kind of know that.
February 11th.
Let me go.
When's my birthday?
February 11th.
Hey-ho!
Hey!
Adam's favorite type of chair?
Oh, gosh.
A Barcalounger?
I'm sorry.
Do you have a weird chair?
You're just happy to sit.
Yeah, it's fun to sit.
I'll take a floor. The floor is fine.
What's my favorite yoga pose?
Oh, that's easy.
Downward mayonnaise.
Do yourself a favor if you want to laugh.
Murder Mystery 2.